[Applaudissements]
ceux qui sont restés en plateau j'ai
pris les plus sportifs comme nous les
dix puisqu'on va réaliser un 100 m 1 100
m 2 malades
je vais vraiment les chronométrés sur un
100 m je demande à robert devenir près
de moi robert notre a bien entendu
votants est ce que vous savez quel
record au 100 m oui c'est pas 9 58 9 58
exactement le temps de record d'un 100
mètres c'est 9 secondes 58 on va voir
combien ont offert deux chroniqueurs il
y en a déjà deux qui sont partis il ya
isabelle morini bosc et maxime gainey et
à doc gynéco qui est en train de
s'entraîner et on va le retrouver dans
un instant mais pour le moment on va
faire partir isabelle morini bosc
sachez qu'un mec normal franchement au
100 m il fait 15 secondes
un mec voilà qui est un peu sportif
casse 14 15 secondes
voilà un mec comme malek effet qu'un
seul on va voir combien fait isabelle
morini bosc
je veux savoir qui est le plus rapide de
l'équipe attention on va donner le
départ il faut lire que c'est laisse
tomber son dentier à 50 pète elle
s'arrête pas pour le ramasser elle
continue merci à le voir vous faites
cuire malek ça peut être l'avez lu bien
attention trois deux un top mais sa voix
pas avancé depuis déjà quinze secondes à
la fermeture un jour que je ne la vois
pas avancé mais est en fait sans révéler
quel petit où elle est loin la temps et
c est ça qui compte mais ce rêve n'est
fait gaffe régate isa et on tirait pas
de calais gibus dans le sketch de la
boîte
déjà que je suis déjà pas mal
mais voilà bois très bon attention
attention attention il a fait gaffe
thierry c'est bien bonal à 23 secondes
83 secondes après tout ce temps est à la
fois en 23 secondes 80 isabelle quelles
sont tes impressions bachir et galana
bien près de moi et franchement fort je
te jure c'est toujours été nul pour les
départs ça c'est confirmé je vous jure
qu'elle a bien couru 23 secondes 80
c'est pas si nul on va avoir tout de
suite c'est le temps de référence
prologue je me rendre ça serait merci
merci
attention maxime gagny maxime gagné
maxime gagné giro mais maxime à ce que
tu es prêt 3 2 un top
il avoue j'ai l'impression qu'il avait
suivi
et la pression qui n'avance nuit allez
allez allez allez allez allez les gars
fait gaffe à toi tu vas pas de bt va pas
de blessé cette seconde 96 secondes 80
16 84 81 bravo
cette seconde 80 m à steam tu sais que
c'est sur le cadran c'est pas si mal
vraiment non non c'est pas mal c'est
pourquoi j'ai pas fait de sport mais
franchement c'est souvent 80 il est
devant izard mais il a fait appel à tous
de regarder peut garder vos pancartes
comme ça vous gardez bien vos pancartes
vous met à côté
yes 23 secondes 96 81 vous avez le sénat
vous avez fait 80 tous les deux alors
attention
jean michel maire est prêt jean michel
maire est prêt comme elle va faire
attention c'est parti
jean michel mr top on n'avance pas du
tout
je pense qu'il va faire moins qu'ils
arrêtent je pense qu'il va faire plus qu
il a en fait il à faire il va faire 25
secondes
j'ai déjà dit second frère allez allez
allez allez va secondes 46 centièmes à
ses ventes 46 je suis à côté maxime
délit malek qui peut décaler mon chéri
du placo qu'une bad things et me voilà
rassuré 46 merci robert merci robert
attention on doit avoir trois jambes
c'est pas toujours un avantage
merci en tout cas vous êtes très drôle
attention et on va maintenant passer à
doc gynéco ouvre à se mettre doc gynéco
ce qui va faire plus qu'ils à mieux que
maxime ou mieux que jean-michel
attention est ce qu'il nous voit bien là
déjà
attention trois deux un top en coton est
déjà comparé les jeunes amis santoro
allez allez c'est bon ah ouais confie
ses cartes
ah ouais mais 17 secondes 30 août
si jusqu'à hier le super g aux jeux pop
je pense qu'il aurait pu patil a débattu
théologales avant tout est relevé à la
fin malheureusement tu dis relevé à la
fin alors 17 secondes rendu de mes
toiles à mon dock mais toi là mettez
vous bien
mettez vous bien la ligne est donc le
grand gagnant c'est maxime gainey